there's another technology called
aeroponics where you suspend the roots
in a plastic container and then atomized
the nutrients in a very small amount of
water it's a it's a huge success in
terms of saving water and feeding plants
at the same time the israelis are using
it like crazy so while these
technologies were developed by desert
dwellers with high degrees of technology
and Israel is one of those places and
the University of Arizona in Tucson is
another place where controlled indoor
farming has been developed to a very
very high level and in fact the reason
why is because NASA would love to grow
food on Mars all right I guess they
think everything is collapsing they have
to leave soon too bad you have to do it
here first you have to learn how to do
it here first okay so even if you want
to live on Mars or you want to develop a
moon colony even or you want to live in
the space station you just you know how
much it costs to shuttle food up there
this dominos does not deliver in this
area I'm sorry you can call them you'll
say where are you the dark side of the
moon ii III know that was a pink floyd
album because i recall your you're
basically committed to reinvent
agriculture if you want your food to be
as close to your plate as it can
possibly be in order to save fossil fuel
use in order to avoid food spoilage in
order to get a continuous growth of crop
in order to avoid weather-related crop
failures I'm now giving you the reasons
why vertical farming started to appeal
to me as a as an academic exercise first
and the next year of course I went back
to the class and I said hey guess what
our project is this year now we get to
talk about farming inside buildings in
large quantities I said what can we farm
inside anyway you know that's your
project for the year you tell me what we
can grow indoors to confluence to to
commercial levels and they came back
with a huge list because NASA already
had that list that was an easy with any
only pretended that they really worked
their tails off but actually it took him
like three hits on the internet to get
the answer and that's too bad not okay
we need to do
so how much more do we need to do in
order to ensure the fact that we've got
solid evidence that raising food indoors
is a good idea yet the best evidence is
commercial viability so they found this
website called euro fresh euro fresh is
a farm outside Tucson Arizona it's 40
acres it's huge they raised tons of
tomatoes the only thing wrong is that
you've got to ship them someplace and
Phoenix doesn't consume all those
tomatoes neither does Tucson so so the
fact is that you're still shipping food
some other place but it's done without
soil it's done in the middle of a desert
where you have an unlimited supply of
sunlight and so it's a great idea
because land is cheap the Sun is free
and they've made a fortune by the way
they've really succeeded now they're
branching out into green beans and and
cucumbers and I guess they're going to
go into a bunch of fruits also because
because it's been economically viable
for them to do this they're not the only
one that's done it in the wintertime go
to the go fairway market in New York
City and you can buy tomatoes from
Holland or from New Zealand again a
little bit far away from me I think and
it's three dollars and ninety-nine cents
a pound that was last year this show be
four dollars and ninety-nine cents a
pound in order to keep up with a fair
trade agreements because soil-based
tomatoes have now doubled in price and
the reason of course is because fossil
fuels have gone up and people are now
growing things that are not food items
for biofuel production in this sort of
thing so it's making a big switch in
terms of our crop selections there okay
so back to the story that was very
encouraging the second year's results
were extremely encouraging because not
only can we raise food inside we can
raise almost everything we need not
everything you can't raise a cow inside
okay you can't raise well you could
raise pigs inside if you'd like a lot of
animal rights people would object to
that so we've eliminated that as a
possibility but no one objects to
chickens I don't know why they're just
animals too but apparently the feeling
is that they're there modern dinosaurs
right birds are modern dinosaurs so
therefore you can kill them because
dinosaurs are mean nasty critters shrimp
farming is a lot of viable option here
mollusks of various kinds in fact
aquaculture is really a fantastic
adjunct to the vertical farm concept too
so when you add it all up you could in a
single building have all the four main
food groups you would have your
vegetables and your your starches and
your you have spats with regards to the
animal products from these crops that I
just mentioned to you and you can have
spices and herbs and everything else you
need in order to live comfortably except
for beef okay so that was great I mean
um you know we made a big list of these
things and so the third year I that was
the crunch here the third year was how
big a building do you need to feed
50,000 people all right let's get real
about this come on show me I mean if I
have to build this thing up to the
stratosphere forget about it it's just
not going to work so tell me here are
the crops here are the methods show me
what's possible with a building and
you've got as much land and as much
money as you want go ahead and they had
a great time with this one because we
know when you're given an infinite
amount of money your tendency is to
spend it all but they didn't they
actually came up with a realistic
building or the building was only 30
stories tall and it was a the footprint
was one square city block of New York
that's five acres of land basically and
the reason why they could feed 50,000
people a year was not obvious from just
those figures what they would have to do
is explain it a little bit more and so
they did they said well you can layer
crops inside of a single room of a
single species of crop let's say like
rice for instance the tallest rice
plants that nasa has identified as
useful for space travel and if you want
rice is about a foot and a half tall
plant now if you have a 10-foot story
building 10 foot high ceiling rather in
a in a 30-story building how many rows
of of rice can you fit into a single
five acre room and the answers about
four layers so that's five times four
that's 20 acres of outside land oh now
it starts to make sense to me too
because once you
you see the ratio of indoor versus
outdoor crops now that's just land that
means you only get one crop a year but
indoors you can get how many crops a
year how long does it take to grow rice
how long does it take to grow wheat how
long does it take to grow tomatoes and
you add up those lengths some time and
that doesn't mean anything to indoor
farming anymore now you can get three or
four crops per year or you can get
continuous crop production now you're
going to say well has this ever been
done before the answer is ask anybody
who runs a greenhouse and the answer is
yeah it has been but it's never been
figured out at this scale before okay so
this is the big thing right so this is
about as big as it's going to get I
think in terms of thinking about raising
food so five acres of land times four is
twenty acres times for because you might
get four crops that's 80 acres now 80
acres of land outdoors that you don't
have to farm on anymore what could you
do with those 80 acres I know I'll
return them to nature and I'll let them
soak up the co2 that we're putting into
the atmosphere from our fossil fuel use
and what used to be forest is now
farmland could again be forest you want
the proof of that go to Korea I know
that seems to be red hair and if where
did that come from but the Demilitarized
Zone that lies between north and south
korea was created in 1953 that it was
all farmland but now it's 10 miles of
don't go here you should see what that
looks like it's the most beautiful place
on earth why did it take a bloody war
between two countries in order to create
the most beautiful place on earth
there's a huge irony and all of that by
the way but here we are looking at it
and saying ji which the rest of the
world could be like that so imagine what
the borders of all the countries would
look like if it became an international
law that says okay you've got to take
five miles of wide border and convert it
back to what it used to be this country
does it this country so you've got 10
miles of a green belt and so from outer
space you can actually see the countries
you know there they are those like
spelled out for you
in green all right this basically is
nothing wrong with that in every country
could afford at least that much but
that's not what I'm actually suggesting
that was just a mind game thing what I'm
really suggesting is that if you think
that there's no solution to a
urbanization the population increase and
ABC the decrease in food production if
you think there's no solution to that
then you can just turn this off right
now but if you think that by applying
what we already know to a new situation
then you can create the next Green
Revolution and that's exactly what I'm
suggesting